- I'm Machine Gun Kelly.
I'm here on the Kelly Clarkson Show,
and she's actually gonna help me surprise
one of my favorite fans.
She's nine years old, about to turn 10,
and I got her birthday invite.
So, me and Chevelle actually
met onstage for the first time
when I saw her, she was singing
every word to all my songs,
and I brought her on stage,
and she stole the show
in front of 10,000 people,
just play the clip.
♪ I can't get enough of it ♪
♪ I swear to God, I never fall in love ♪
♪ I never fall in love, but
I can't get enough of it ♪
Since I couldn't make it to
the actual birthday party,
I'm gonna surprise her on here.
So, she thinks she's talking
to a producer on the show,
however, it's just me.
- Hey, so I heard you're a
really big Machine Gun Kelly fan.
- I am, I love him so much
that I'm even wearing the shirt
that I wore to the concert.
I love his music so much,
'cause it's so good.
And I like to listen to it in the car,
and I love to dance to it and sing to it.
- Well, I do have another producer here
that just is gonna chat with you
and ask you a couple
more formal questions.
- Okay.
(dramatic music)
- Hi!
- Hi.
- Last time I saw you,
we were rocking the stage together,
and you did way better of a job than me.
I should have just let you
finish the whole show off.
You did so good.
How old are you turning?
- 10.
- You're turning 10?
Okay, so I got the birthday invite.
I actually have to go out
of the country tomorrow,
but since I can't be there,
can I sing something for you instead?
♪ Happy Birthday to you ♪
♪ Happy Birthday to you, Chevelle, yeah ♪
(upbeat music)
Happy 10th Birthday, Chevelle.
Thank for rocking with me
and being down with my music.
I really do appreciate that,
and that memory you made with me on stage
will stick with me forever,
so I really am very appreciative of you.
I also, before I go, did
get you a birthday present.
So, could you guys bring
in the birthday present?
Something for you to hold on to from me.
It's my signature guitar,
so you can hang it up,
or you can learn to play
it, or whatever you want,
but that's my thank you for your life.
- Thank you.
(Chevelle crying)
- As you grow in this life,
and as things try to take away your light,
just hold onto it and
protect your light, okay?
Don't let people tell you
what to like, or what to do,
or how to be.
You are a light soul,
and just hold on to that,
and protect that, okay?
And happy 10th birthday.
I love you very much.
- Thank you.
- Bye.
(bells chiming)
- Okay, well, I'm gonna go
cry for two hours in my room
from cuteness overload.
Thank you, Kelly, for
helping us put that together.
Chevelle, happy birthday,
and I'm gonna go wipe all my tears.
(upbeat music)
(bells chiming)